[Music]
three two
one
blocked off to a new beginning beyond
the stars America's famous for the
notion that it's the land of opportunity
Americans promising more than we can
deliver that's a center of hello
tomorrow start living your brighter
tomorrow today
the show is about
and how a skew it can go
the show's so unique I have a hard time
describing it
hello tomorrow is about a bunch of
salesmen they're selling time shares for
a property on the Moon called the bright
side it's a futuristic story told in a
retro way
[Music]
exactly I was interested
you're introduced to this world through
jack Billings he's got a sales team of
Misfits and vagabonds Shirley absolutely
runs this business incredibly shrewd
very capable perfect counterpart to Jack
they're giving people an opportunity to
hope for a better future
the bright side that's a place for real
people to start fresh unwind retire
it is 1950s retro future the sets cars
clothing there's something so fun about
imagining a world that's never been seen
before
we built a lot of the robots practically
you've got puppeteers remote control
they make a lot of noise I have so many
emotional scenes but in the background
is this little one-eyed tin can
the beginning of the show is defined by
such optimism
delivering smiles
and then very quickly it is made clear
there is a lot more ominous undertones
it's
how good things can be without the
troops getting in the way
[Music]
I found it incredibly entertaining to
imagine a world that's talking about the
spirit of American salesmanship Jack
compulsively seeks happiness and to
satisfy anyone in front of him that
sense of hopefulness as lie upon lie
begins to crumble down
I've never seen it put on page before
we rely on storytelling to make sense of
our world in this alternative future
nothing is any different all the gadgets
break at a certain point your bartender
robot might be able to serve you a beer
from its belly but there might be a
little bit of motor oil in it
we promise Perfection and what we
deliver as human
I'm excited for audiences to see the Kim
chemistry on set that can't be on there
we do a lot of laughing but it's quite
emotional at the same time I will burn
this whole place to the ground
this is about what we still all Wrestle
with what's the truth what's a lie what
do I actually believe in it is funny
and thoughtful
and odd but everybody in their own way
is trying to be a better human
foreign